bonsoir le clown ne rie est plus il
s'est donné la mort
en fait que tu as je ne marche sur le
pied
et puis une seconde
il est passé
vous ne mangez pas peur
il s'appelait zavatta il avait 78 ans il
était accablé par les difficultés
financières du cirque familial
affaibli par la maladie il n'attendait
plus rien de la vie il s'est tiré une
balle dans la tête eric lemasson
christophe tortora roger mathurin
tout ce que je peux vous dire c'est
qu'il souffrait beaucoup ces derniers
temps
et que certainement pas résisté pour les
enfants les clowns n'ont pas d'âge
achille zavatta ce matin c'est pourtant
senti bien view sur le perron de la
maison où il s'était retiré ici à ozoir
deschamps d'un coup de fusil en pleine
tête
le clown a mis fin à ses jours ce visa
depuis deux ans savate un malade avait
quitté sa caravane pour vivre dans ce
pavillon avec sa jeune épouse
loin des chapiteaux non loin d'un
village où entre deux séances de dialyse
à l'hôpital
il aimait aller jouer à la belote la
dernière partie c'était dimanche dernier
on a fait une belle partie de cartes et
pis on a bu l'apéritif ensemble a su
comment et éthique ces derniers temps
ils étaient très malades très fatigué je
l'emmenais moi même avec la voiture
lp on passe à une petite après midi
ensemble chapiteau achille zavatta paris
près de la bastille la relève c'est le
fils d'achille qui l'a prise pour les
employés du siècle cet après midi une
grande tristesse
mais dès demain à 15 heures les artistes
entreront en piste
spectacle continue commentait hier c'est
malheureux c'est comme ça la vie un
spectacle
voyage zavatta avait mis 15 ans pour
créer son propre cirque
il ya quelques années les difficultés
financières l'avaient contraint à vendre
c'est pourtant la souffrance physique
qui avait atteint le moral d'achille
zavatta devenu presque aveugle le clown
ne voyait plus brillé devant lui le
regard des enfants les plus jeunes ne le
connaissais pas mais les jeunes vont-ils
encore au cirque les plus âgés
l'apprécié pour ses facéties et son rire
rabelaisien il y avait fait la fortune
de la télé des années 60 avant que la
télé ne fasse la faillite du cirque
traditionnel et ne se détournent de la
piste aux étoiles jean jacques dufour
françoise david
ouvrez donc les yeux plus qu le clou les
mots
pourrait donc les lumières puis ce
colloque loin de la piste qu'il avait
quitté il ya quelques années le flux
s'est suicidé la piste le siècle c'était
toute la vie d'achille zavatta
d'ailleurs dans la famille c'est un
métier que l'on pratiqué depuis le 15e
siècle l'origine piémontaise h il fut
tour à tour trapézistes et huillet
dompteur musiciens clowns il le devint
par hasard en remplaçant un artiste qui
avait raté son train c'était en 1934 il
avait 20 ans
que vous savez quand on mène une vie
comme la nôtre je crois qu'on a la plus
belle existence on puisse avoir dans ce
métier là c'est vrai c'est formidable
en voyageant change de ville on voit le
monde entier on est libre à 63 ans au
fait de sa gloire zavatta s'offre son
propre cirque 70 véhicules qui
sillonneront les routes jusqu'à la
liquidation judiciaire difficile de
faire des affaires dans un monde de
comptables ou la poésie du cirque semble
désuète
surtout quand on est plus saltimbanques
que géomètre
d'une petite voix comme il n'en avait
jamais eu
il parle de l'amour de la joie sans être
cru
pour lui la mort d'un cirque du cirque
impensable
le ciel ne pas mourir c'est je crois
c'est là c'est la seule chose qui va
exister culte un cerf-volant comprennent
des six volets comprenez pas c'est beau
et on comprenne et et si vous les
comptes rené par annie fratellini
bonsoir vous comprenez je comprends je
trouve merveilleux de pour un homme de
ne plus accepter de ne pas fait rire de
ne plus travailler en fait de quitter la
vie parce qu'en fait c'est ce qu'il y
avait de plus important pour lui qui est
mort le l'homme où le clown je pense que
c'est l'homme qui est mort et le clown
ne meurt jamais en fait les clowns ne
meurt pas il se passe une chaîne comme
ça continue depuis 200 ans avant il y
avait les bouffons et depuis en fait 2
120 et se passe comme ça un chaînon et
chaque luna porte à l'autre qui va le
suivre
quelque chose de puces en fait pourquoi
un geste aussi aussi violent si
spectaculaire une balle dans la tête
mais je trouve ça admirable
je trouve ça admirable parce que je ne
savais pas qu'il était si malade je
savais qu'il s'était retiré
je pense que plus que les soucis en fait
c'est le fait peut-être de ne plus
travailler car en fait pour un clown
comme celui là qui a passé toute sa vie
dans de cire qui a fait rire tout ça
vibre c'est pas seulement le riz ou
c'est le clown ça dépasse le rire c'est
vrai qu'on pense toujours au côté
dramatique du clown et c'est vrai qu'il
y a un côté dramatique surtout quand il
arrive des choses comme celles là et
beaucoup de cloud se sont suicidés oui
comme des humoristes d'ailleurs vous
l'aviez vu récemment j'ai vu la dernière
fois y ait cinq ans j'ai pas vu depuis
ils restent en contact avec le monde du
cirque
mais il vivait la vie du ciel vous savez
quand on travaille dans un cirque avis
si rude si passionnante aussi qu'on n'a
pas le temps de voir autre chose
ailleurs
et c'est vrai que zavatta h il était un
homme qui vivait passionnément cette
villa de canton quand on s'est
rencontrés quand on se rencontre on a
travaillé surtout musicaux l'ensemble
enfin bizarrement notre rencontre a été
faite à l'olympia lorsque lui était en
pleine gloire avec la piste aux étoiles
et que moi je débutais comme chanteuse
et de noms comme cela moi qui rognait ma
famille du cirque l'hymne allemand est
lui qui ne la renie pas mais qu'il a
remis un petit peu en venant music hall
c'est vrai c'était une rencontre assez
bizarre et que après nous sommes tous
les deux lui acheter un cirque et moi
j'ai fait l'école du siècle c'est vrai
que finalement c'est quelque chose qui
vous tient le cirque un justement est-ce
que par cette violence dirigée contre
lui n'a pas voulu signer
et la mort du ciel je crois pas ce qu'il
disait avant que le ciel ne peut pas
mourir les coûts non plus je pense
sincèrement qu'il ya toujours eu des
bouffons et tant qu'il y aura des hommes
au coeur d'enfant je pense qu'il y aura
des clous et puis les clowns c'est comme
les poètes ça ne ment jamais justement
henry miller avait une très belle phrase
le clown est un poète c'est le poète un
accent l'action il est l'histoire qu'il
joue il ya encore place pour la poésie
aujourd'hui oui il y aura encore des nez
rouges
oui il y en a à l'école mais enfin
partout je dire dans le monde entier il
y en a heureusement le cirque est bien
vivant avec des difficultés mais il y en
a toujours eu quand on se penche sur son
histoire
c'est évident que c'est une longue
histoire difficile mais c'est pour ça
que le cirque et si passionnant et six
bouts merci fratellini annie merci
beaucoup
ni remords ni redemption les militants
d'action directe déjà condamné à la
perpétuité pour l'assassinât de georges
besse est jugé à nouveau pour celui de
rené audran se sont montrés agressifs à
l'ouverture du procès à paris et ont
provoqué plusieurs suspensions de séance
isabelle steiss roger motte le temps
passe pas la peur le dispositif policier
reste à la mesure de leur réputation
dans ce fourgon blindé
les quatre terroristes les plus connus
de france aujourd'hui pourtant ils ne
sont plus que les militants d'une cause
perdue
action directe 4 matricule isolé depuis
six ans dans une cellule de fresnes
déjà condamné à la perpétuité
aujourd'hui en grève de la faim
il se présente une dernière fois devant
leurs juges quinze gendarmes les
encadrent dans le box est tout de suite
c'est l'incident cipriani veut lire un
communiqué refus du président rouillan
se lève on s'en va dit-il les gendarmes
l'empoignent foutez lui la paix hurle
ménigon première suspension d'audience
évacuation à la reprise les deux femmes
ont le sourire ironique les soupirs
exaspéré nathalie ménigon prend la
parole j'ai décidé de mener le combat
armé contre ce [ __ ] de système
j'en suis vraiment heureuse je suis
prête à recommencer demain elle se lève
insulte la justice nouvelle suspension
il y aura ainsi
quatre suspensions d'audience pour cause
d'incident et même une alerte à la bombe
nous sommes militant révolutionnaire et
nous n'avons pas l'intention de
cautionner ce rituel judiciaire a
prévenu joëlle aubron
il faut dire que les quatre dirigeants
d'action directe n'ont plus rien à
perdre ils savent déjà que cette emprise
on est pour très longtemps qu'ils
continueront leur combat hier au procès
villemin à dijon le juge lambert s'était
dit convaincu de l'innocence de la roche
aujourd'hui le commandant de gendarmerie
cesma expriment un avis contraire
on comprend pourquoi l'assassinât du
petit grégory reste un mystère dominique
verdeilhan eric de lannion l'honneur
d'un capitaine le 16 octobre 84
il fut l'un des premiers sur les bords
de la vologne aujourd'hui c'était
éprouvant plus il averti
sous la chambre ça faisait huit ans que
j'attendais ce moment soulagement
soulagement de dire que pour lui il
fallait pour suivre la piste la roche
soulagement aussi de dire ce qu'il pense
du juge lambert de son manque de sérieux
je ne veux pas en rajouter par rapport à
ce qui a été dit hier mais avec lui on
n'a pas pu aller jusqu'au bout alors les
médias ont occupé le vide après le juge
jean michel lambert et lui maurice simon
il a reculé son départ en retraite pour
tenter d'élucider la faire jusqu'à y
laisser sa santé
c'est maître jacques les hôtes et qui
fut un moment avocats dans le dossier
grégory qui lui rend un hommage appuyé
et cornemps au passage le juge jean
michel lambert
je ne comprends pas comment
avec cette évidence des chronomètres et
du temps nécessaire pour mettre un
enfant à l'eau qui a été estimé compte
tenu des rapports des médecins légistes
à 4 à 5 minutes vois pas comment on peut
dire que on croit à la culpabilité d'une
personne comme christine villemin
troisième juge dans le dossier deuxième
juge à la barre jean paul martin il a
refermé le dossier grégory par un
non-lieu pour christine villemin
devant la cour d'assises il fait état
d'éléments qui l'ont poussé à croire que
bernard laroche a enlevé grégory et l'on
relèvera aujourd'hui le sentiment d'un
magistrat exprimés à la barre devant la
cour d'assises
dans un dossier de procédure il n'y a ni
pleurs ni sueur c'est quelque chose
d'assez petit zay et qui peut être un
danger
mince consolation une cour d'assises
offre aujourd'hui à la justice
l'occasion de donner à ce dossier
une vraie dimension israéliens et
palestiniens continuent de négocier en
egypte malgré la détérioration du climat
au sud liban et dans les territoires
occupés le nombre d'accrochages augmente
le nombre de morts aussi un jeune
palestinien a été tué et charles
enderlin
il sort azzaoui vient d'apprendre que
son fils rami a été tué par un soldat
il avait 16
des voisins des amis et des dirigeants
palestiniens viennent présenter leurs
condoléances au père isaac azzaoui c'est
un des principaux partisans du processus
de paix en cisjordanie où cette affaire
suscite de vives réactions
je ne demande pas l'arrêt des
négociations mais j'exige des dirigeants
israéliens qu'un contrôleur soldats et
leurs colons et les éloigne de nous
l'accrochage s'est déroulé ici devant ce
lycée des jeunes palestiniens ont lancé
des pierres sur une patrouille qui ont
ouvert le feu tuant ramin et blessant
deux adolescents alice a été touché à
l'abdomen
dans ces conditions les dirigeants
palestiniens craignent de perdre le
contrôle des populations dans les
territoires occupés nous avons été assez
courageux pour condamner des actions de
certains nogent contre les ordres alors
j'ai écrit à monsieur rabine pour qu'il
nous dise on les colons et les soldats
agissent selon ses ordres et sinon il
les condamne
l'armée ne tire pas des coups de semonce
ce regain de tension intervient alors
que les négociations entre israël et
l'olp et sont dans une passe difficile
sarajevo sous la neige la guerre en
bosnie va devenir encore plus laides
dominique derda sarajevo sous la neige
l'hiver est en avance sur le calendrier
bientôt et pour de longs mois la
température ne dépassera plus zéro degré
la capitale est calme les bombardements
plus rares ces jours derniers mais le
froid la faim peuvent s'avérer plus
mortelle encore que la guerre d'autant
que les provisions manque
comme toujours les produits à vendre au
marché sont hors de prix et l'aide
humanitaire une fois encore est bloquée
autour de zénith ça en bosnie centrale
les convois ne passe plus les combats
entre croates et musulmans empêchent
toute livraison de vivres de couverture
quand ce ne sont pas les combattants eux
mêmes croates serbes qui bloquent le
passage ils ont déjà connu un hiver très
dur celui qui commence maintenant
s'annonce plus dure encore
les gens n'ont plus aucune réserve nous
n'avons livré que très peu de nourriture
aujourd'hui plus du tout alors oui cet
hiver commence vraiment très mal sur
l'ancien stade de sarajevo devenu
cimetière on se hâte de creuser à
l'avance de nouvelles tombes
bientôt le seul orage les bientôt c'est
sûr il y aura d'autres
or dans les pays en paix comme le nôtre
des hommes et des femmes peuvent aussi
souffrir du mauvais temps ceux qui n'ont
pas de toit et qui voit arriver l'hiver
avec une forte angoisse marque
maisonneuve et bruno girodon ont passé
une partie de la nuit à paris avec deux
sans abri derrière le grand palais pour
paul et maurice on ne vit pas une époque
formidable passé la nuit quand on a
l'habitude de la rue cela commence
toujours par la chasse aux cartes au le
meilleur moyen de s'isoler du sol et du
froid
paul à la démarche mal assurée car il a
les chaussures d'un autre on les lui a
donné il ne les a pas choisi derrière le
grand palais à 100 mètres des champs
elysées une des avenues les plus chères
du monde
paul et son lit cela fait 20 ans qu'il
vit dehors il avait à peine 30 ans quand
sa vie a basculé
il allait se marier le trouble à l'élan
créé malades
et les cannes de l'alchimie du mois pour
la lutte est décédé il est fou
et une grande dame qui m'a sauvé dumas
la misère j'ai joué du violon à l'opéra
de paris et caen
73 kitty ce métier j'ai profité
on m'a cassé la gueule maps etc et le
foyer premier qui sert à faire là les
fameuses notes après la cloche depuis
qu'il n'a plus de toit pour folle la vie
se résume à une lutte contre la faim et
le froid
j'ai vu tant qu il a fait froid dans
quatre ans afin d'être obligé de me
lever faire un tour du bâtiment pour me
réchauffer chez moi tant que je vais
parfois au pied salah à ses yeux trop
perso alors la terminer dans l'écurie
mois et la vieille on est on est les
deux rescapés le chenil et on le boiteux
le basque puis son fils mans pour les
vieux de la vieille de la rue comme eux
le métro n'est pas un refuge pire que le
froid c'est un coupe gorge
il laisse donc les couloirs on les
exclut mireille dumas consacrera ce soir
à 22h25 son émission sans abri la
télévision au service de l'emploi
edouard balladur souhaite que le
programme d'avant art et donc avant 19h
soit consacré à la formation et l'emploi
avant la mise en place l'hiver prochain
de chaînes de connaissances le premier
ministre a fait cette déclaration devant
le 66ème congrès des maires dilemme
doit-on dire lagune là où la luna laguna
dit renaud en attendant de connaître la
réponse du ministre de la francophonie
photo france 2 vous présente la voiture
qui succède à la renault 21 catégories
moyennes supérieures rival 405 etc s'en
tient la laguna les autres voitures
essence sont encore une longue route à
faire
à la grande satisfaction des
constructeurs français le temps de la
voiture électrique n'est pas encore
arrivé mais il arrivera c'est sûr alban
nicosie bernard connor
la voiture du vin régnait c'est le
silence a circulé entendre les bruits de
la nature oublier si la production émis
par les voitures à essence suit lomu
bien eu les premiers tours de roues des
voitures électriques aux droits de porte
c'était en 1993 à la rochelle la france
se lance dans l'aventuré au presque à
reculons 500 voitures immatriculées en
cinq ans c'est bien peu
chaque exemplaire coûte alors près de
cent mille francs c'est l'époque des
pionniers
lusine volta près de la rochelle une
petite entreprise leader sur le marché
un cadre tout simple pour l'alimentation
des batteries au nickel cadmium
rudimentaire elles n'offrent alors que
100 km d'autonomie au maximum la moitié
si l'on utilise le chauffage ou
l'éclairage et le temps pour faire le
plein d'énergie et décourageant 8 heures
du coup seuls des administrations comme
france télécom possède des voitures
électriques mais 93 marque un tournant
la fin de l'époque gadget nous avons lu
ici et là à travers l'europe beaucoup de
voitures gadgets effectivement je crois
que cette phase là est enfin de se
terminer pour nous la rochelle nous
avons déjà la volta depuis quelques
années qui sort complètement du domaine
de gadgets puisque actuellement
l'entreprise en fabrique une vingtaine
par mois une vingtaine par mois le
chiffre peut prêter à sourire mais en 93
les voitures classiques ou de beaux
jours devant elle la voiture électrique
reste un projet pour le futur et
seulement cela
messieurs vous n'aurez plus d'excusés
quand madame vous demandera de faire la
lessive vous ne pourrez plus refuser
mais entre nous ce sera facile grâce à
une boule magique inventé en allemagne
vraiment magique
en quête de pascal guimier ralf klingler
une enquête est pas des plus faciles
maigre indice que ces quelques lignes à
la une d'un grand quotidien sensation
laver le linge sans les six lui lave
linge et est donc possible
un homme un seul pouvait nous répondre
monsieur glotz unique détenteur à ce
jour une ovation
on aurait peut-être rêver la mère denis
démonstration une boule avec un micro
moteurs fonctionnant sur piles
rechargeables ronronnement production de
basse fréquence
les molécules entre en folie et la
saleté et chasser des fibres sans que le
linge et besoin d'être frotter notre
créneau c'est plutôt la petite lessive
de tous les jours pour les vacanciers
pour les campeurs vient quand on veut
laver des tissus fragiles à froid comme
le cachemire ou la soie en revanche pour
le linge vraiment sale pour les nappes
pour les draps il faudra toujours
utiliser des machines à laver comme
avant notre invention n'est pas là pour
les remplacer en tout cas c'est propre
le résultat de quelques années de
recherches pour si l'inventeur du
dimanche l'engin pourrait être
commercialisé en allemagne début 94 pour
un prix d'environ 350 francs mais
attention
deux heures de charge pour une demi
heure d'autonomie seulement alors les
fabricants de l'ici et de lave linge
m'ont guère de raison de s'inquiéter
quant à moi le contrat a été rempli et
l'anc est terminée clairefontaine ça
sonne comme un poème mais les hommes qui
s'y trouvent se comporte en guerrier
veillée d'armes ce soir avant la grande
bataille france bulgarie
l'enjeu est capital il s'appelle
l'amérique laurent frédéric bollée
didier renquet et dire qu'il voulait se
mettre au vert à clairefontaine
objectif raté les joueurs l'entraîneur
et toute l'équipe de france n'échappe à
la médiatisation et à une certaine
pression
aujourd'hui on l'a senti la tension est
encore montée d'un cran
les petites phrases du week-end sont
apparemment oublié mais certains à
propos de cette préparation très
surveillés ont des choses à dire
j'avoue quand comment présenter un petit
peu la préparation de l'équipe du gard
on s'aperçoit que c'est tout juste s'ils
partent pas en guerre je veux dire ils
sont isolés on sait pas où ils sont ils
ont interdiction de parler à la presse
ça fait un petit peu commando je crois
que pour gagner ce genre de match
cette ultime manche finalement pour se
qualifier il faut avoir un esprit
commando preuve quand même qu'une guerre
des nerfs s'est engagée contre la
bulgarie gérard houllier ne communiquera
son équipe que demain au dernier moment
tactique
il faudra aussi effacer le souvenir
cauchemar du match contre israël et les
sifflets cadets reçu un certain jpp
j'ai une réaction d'orgueil après le
magistral je pense que c'est normal je
peux j'estime que ce chiffre n'était pas
tout à fait justifié même si bon pour
une fois j'ai fait à la hauteur tant
qu'on n'a pas tous à la hauteur on a
enlevé onze dans les mêmes cas je crois
qu'on l'a pas sifflé achats en
particulier bon je crois que on s'est
manqué à paris l'autre fois simplement
maintenant il faut gagner un match
important contre la bulgarie sur point
de manquer alors maintenant que ginola
le rebelle est rentré dans le rang
maintenant que les joueurs ne sont plus
branchés que sur les états unis
il ne reste plus qu'à se lancer aux
lakers si la loi des séries existent et
la france devraient se qualifier
novembre 60 17 novembre 80 novembre 85
le dernier match joué par la france pour
la qualification en coupe du monde a été
toujours décisif dans les trois cas
victoire donc
écoutons leurs faivre michel platini que
françois brabant et thierry clopeau ont
rencontré 16 novembre 1977 dernier match
des qualifications france bulgarie au
parc l'équipe de platini doit coûte que
coûte gagner pour se qualifier la coupe
du monde en argentine après rouge tout
en première mi temps c'est platini qui
fait chavirer toute la france sur ce tir
canon hagman sa mère
platini a alors 21 ans victoire 3 2 1 et
l'équipe de france est découverte
un douzième homme on avait un parc
extraordinaire ce jour là je m'en
souviens ce parc nous avait poussés dans
nos derniers retranchements mais le
match aller avait été épique est le
public s'en souvenait ce qui s'était
passé avec monsieur foot et donc on
avait un public extraordinaire de 81,2
on avait un public un peu mitigé 86,8
est plus tranquille plus serein parce
que nous avions une bonne équipe
heureusement si vous voulez bien 18
novembre 80 france pays bas ce soir là
un coup franc historique de michel
platini qui est au sommet de son art
contre les vice-champions du monde
l'équipe de france prouve qu'elle fait
partie du gotha international
une victoire 2 0 et un tic pour lesparre
saluant même 5 même six ans 27 ans tous
de michel d'avoir fait le pari de jouer
avec trois numéros 10 pari insensé mais
qui a bien marché vul à la personnalité
surtout des milieux de terrain qui
composaient ccc trop quatre joueurs et
ça a été un match difficile on n'a pas
eu beaucoup d'occasions marque sur un
coup franc marqua la fin mais l'équipe
de hollande était très forte
17 novembre 85 francs su que cela dit un
nul suffit pour le voyage au mexique
mais platini ne l'entend pas de cette
oreille
docteur ès coups francs a juste sans
pitié le goal yougoslave et propulser la
france dans sa troisième coupe du monde
consécutive de m'asseoir platine ne sera
pas là mais pour la route les derniers
petits conseils d'un vieux renard je
pense ce que le 17 novembre il y aura
certainement des joueurs sur marqué les
buts mais même ce jour là sûrement pas
de buts que l'on prend est toujours
qualifié mais on est ce qu'on peut jouer
au chat et à la souris comme ça je crois
qu'il faut jouer sur sa valeur et puis
le match en fonction de ses qualités jeu
c'est possible à bon entendeur salut
messieurs l'amérique lui tend les bras
le plus grand musée du monde ajoute un
tableau à son trésor un tableau de
lumières composées par un mécène qui
entre chez vous chaque soir
edf patrick esther vous l'offre en avant
première encore quelques jours et le
ciel de la ville lumière brillera d'une
flamme nouvelle le louvre à son tour va
rayonner de dix mille étoiles
d-will lente judicieusement placés sur
les corniches qui illumineront les
façades d'un pas les juger autrefois
austère par louis xiv
les lignes de lumière qui détache et
détails architecturaux uzols chaque
barreau liait une véritable sculpture
lumineuse pour parvenir à ce résultat
les équipes de l'éclairage public
d'électricité de france ont utilisé une
technique originale l'image de synthèse
ce que vous voyez maintenant ce sont des
dessins obtenu par de savants calculs
mathématiques
auparavant il a fallu relever les
croquis des vrais façade de l'édifice
car paradoxalement aucun plan précis
n'existait à ce jour grâce à
l'informatique il est possible de tester
tous les effets lumineux sur la pierre
avant même d'avoir installé un seul
projecteur sur le véritable bâtiment
elles ont pu recommencer autant de fois
qu'on le souhaite
du coup il est facile d'éliminer les
ombres disgracieuses est facile de
choisir les emplacements les meilleurs
pour les projecteurs dans la cour carrée
du louvre qu'il était impossible de
poser des luminaires sur le sol un
possible d'éclairer également avec des
projecteurs installés sur les toits en
vis-à-vis sous peine d'éblouir les
visiteurs et puis surtout pas question
d'abîmer les façades historiques de
pierre lescot la solution souder des
plaques sur les bordures de gouttière en
plomb est accrochée sur ses plaques des
rampes lumineuses les projecteurs
spécialement assemblé à la main
contiennent d' impressionnante
collection de lampes au xénon mais
incroyablement discret il se dissimule
parfaitement sur la façade un
authentique exploit
et tous les musées de france aime la
lumière le musée national des arts et
traditions populaires à paris organise à
partir de demain jusqu'au 22 novembre sa
deuxième édition du festival audiovisuel
et sera ouvert aux pays européens et au
canada qui au thiossane la geisha aimé
d'un amour fou pinkerton le marin
américain amours déçues la geisha c'est
alors suicidé
l'auteur de cette histoire l'italien
puccini le titre de son histoire madame
butterfly l'america wilson la met
aujourd'hui en scène le chef est
d'origine coréenne young blood to et le
ténor et russe il joue le rôle de
pinkerton l'opéra bastille s'est
transformé en opéra babel
michel ce que l'officier daniel le faire
sont allés dans la fosse le maestro
chung à l'assaut de puccini
le chef et l'orchestré de l'opéra comme
aucun spectateur ne les voir
voici le langage par singh qui lie chung
ses musiciens et les chanteurs
madame butterfly dans toute sa beauté
dépouillés à la japonaise sur l'immense
scène de l'opéra bastille
un éclairage sans artifice qui renforce
les motions de l'os
souvent je ne demande pas comment ça me
touche si ça me touche déjà ça c'est
quelque chose de très important
et quand j'ai fait cette musique je peux
très facilement pleurer alors ça c'est
une vraie motion naturel n'est ce pas
non
c'est aujourd'hui la sainte marguerite
je vous le précise simplement à la
demande de l'organisation mondiale de la
santé des lion's club qui lance une
campagne contre la cécité
il ya 42 millions d'aveuglés dans le
monde si rien ne change ils seront 80
millions dans 20 ans en france 600 mille
personnes souffrent de la cécité cette
campagne a un nom je donne tu verras ccp
423 et paris vp 88-75 222 paris 0,5
c'est la fin de ce journal le programme
du soir dans quelques instants
sophie davant pour le temps demain
toujours froid est toujours beau à 20h50
la cage aux folles numéro 3 avec michel
serrault gounod
ugo tognazzi évidemment de georges
lautner 22h25 mireille dumas bas les
masques
une émission consacrée aux sans abri
22h40 le journal de philippe lefait
avant le cercle de minuit de michel
field et demain 7h50 gérard leclerc
recevra le président du cni jean antoine
jean syli bonne soirée sur france 2 à
demain vainqueurs dont soir